oui il ya un risque d'être contaminé on
est inquiets pour nos personnes âgées on
est inquiet pour nous oscar c'est que la
peur l'inquiétude
voilà ce que ressentait une partie des
français au début de l'année 2020 la
raison
l'arrivée d'un nouveau virus provenant
de chine 1 coronavirus le 24 janvier le
pays connaît ses trois premiers quart
temps les français s'interrogent dans ce
salut du val d'oise
les médecins sont assaillis d'appels la
plupart du temps c'est des gens
appellent pour ce pour être rassurés
c'est à dire qu'effectivement quand on
revient de chine
si on n'a pas de fièvre pour l'instant
il n'y a pas lieu de s'inquiéter
autre phénomène de panique cette fois
dans les pharmacies comme à lille où les
français ont pris d'assaut les masques
et les gels hydro-alcooliques
c'est quoi la du coup tout est vide
depuis 48 heures les jours passent
l'inquiétude monte direction carry le
rouet dans les bouches du rhône le 31
janvier 2020 cette petite commune
accueille 180 de français rapatriés de
chine
chez certains habitants une psychose
s'installe cette femme est venue jusqu'à
la mairie pour protester mais il ya
quand même 5 à 6 jours d'incubation et
ils vont rester 14 jours dans le salon
vacances y être même scène
d'appréhension cette fois à
crépy-en-valois dans l'oise
c'est là-bas que le premier français
meurent du virus appelé maintenant
kovy 19 par l' oms c'était le 26 février
2020 là encore l'angoissent gagne du
terrain
parfois cette peur d'être contaminés
peut aller loin voire très loin 2 mars
2020 la psychose gagne la martinique
les tensions montent d'un cran à
l'aéroport des étrangers son pris à
partie par les habitants de l'île
pire un car de touristes est attaqué
puis taguer les pneus crevés
nous sommes entrés dans le bus et tous
les gens se sont mis à courir a heurté
le bus et à s'allonger sur le sol devant
le bus c'était complètement tacle le 16
mars 2020 face à la propagation de
l'épidémie
le président emmanuel macron annoncé le
confinement du pays
[Musique]